[MUSIC]
>> Hi, I'm Jessica Lawson one of
the view from the top student leaders.
Thank you for joining us for
our final event of the year.
On behalf of the leadership team,
it's been our greatest honor to serve as
the view from the top student leaders and
to bring you the most diverse speaker
slate in the program's history.
Is our hope that you've learned from and
inspired by these unique stories that
were shared on the virtual stage.
Thank you to Dean Levin, Liz Walker and
the rest of the GSB community for
helping us make this
year's program possible.
And now it is my pleasure to welcome
Dean Levin to introduce today's speaker.
>> Thank you, Jessica.
And before I introduce today's speaker,
I just like to take a minute to thank
this year's view from the top team for
putting together an amazing series.
Adriana Gross, Jessica Lawson,
Joy Wang and Rex Woodbury.
On behalf of the GSB community,
thank you for all your work this year.
And now I'm delighted to have
the opportunity to welcome
Thasunda Brown Duckett the newly
appointed president, and CEO of TIA A.
She was previously the CEO
of Chase consumer banking.
Thasunda has been recognized widely as a
leading executive in the finance industry.
She was named by Fortune as one of
the most powerful women to watch, she was
named one of the most powerful women
in banking by American Banker magazine.
She founded the Rosie and
Otis Brown Foundation in honor for
parents to recognize people who
use ordinary means to empower and
uplift their communities
in extraordinary ways.
She was also one of
the 16 women who inspired
LeBron James's first shoe for women.
The Nike HFR LeBron 16 and
she's now on the board of
directors of the Nike Corporation.
And we're just looking forward so much to
hearing more about Thasunda's achievements
as a leader in today's conversation
with Adriana Gross MBA class of 2021.
>> Wow Thasunda,
that's quite a resume, you're welcome.
And thank you for joining us.
>> Thank you so much.
It's a privilege.
>> You know, I woke up on a Saturday
morning a few weeks ago and
was thinking do I go to the gym or not?
You on the other hand,
woke up on a Saturday a few weeks
ago you were the CEO of TIAA.
>> Absolutely.
>> And
I were just feeling tons of gratitude for
this conversation right now and
I hope you've had a chance to celebrate.
Let it all sink in a little bit.
And, again, thank you for
the work you're doing.
It's an incredible organization, impacting
folks that really are the backbone of
everything we have here in the country.
>> Absolutely.
>> And the success it
doesn't come alone all right?
Dean Levin mentioned,
Otis and Rosie Brown.
>> Yeah.
>> And you said you were on the shoulders
of giants way back when during that move
from the East Coast over to Texas.
How did Otis and
Rosie make this all happen?
>> Well again,
it's such a privilege to have the honor
to speak with all of you and you're right
Adrian when I woke up on that Saturday I
probably did not get to the gym.
But I will say that I woke up and
continued to be full of gratitude.
And you can't have the moment
of being a CEO of a company like
TIAA without being reflected.
And that brings me to,your question when
you think about Otis and Rosie Brown.
They are my anchor, they are my roots.
And when I think about what they mean
to me, my dad taught me to reach for
the moon, and he would say even if you
miss you would be among the stars.
And I am still reaching for that moon.
My mom would always tell me,
whatever you do, you know you do,
you do it with excellence or you don't
do it at all, no matter what it is.
And so those just life lessons along
the way, not just what they said but
what they embodied.
Not what they embody but what I saw
growing up and all the sacrifices.
It's all of that, that allows me
to be in the seat that I am today.
And again, being on the shoulders
of my parents and so
many others before me, has me full
of gratitude and a lot of humility.
>> Absolutely and there were ton of
sacrifices your parents right you told
the story about driving with your car five
of you pack in there every hand in that
car so that says something right.
>> Now,
it doesn't mean when you think about it,
I'm first generation integration.
And it seems so long ago when we talked
about the course of our society,
my dad grew up in the segregated South and
Louisiana my mother grew up,
I'm in Alabama.
They met in New York, but
when we moved to Texas my parents
packed everything that we own.
So it was, three children,
my mom and my dad and
everything that we owned, which is you
can imagine in a car that's not much.
And I always say that that was a real
moment because when I think about it,
when I started my life in
Texas sitting on crates.
And when you think about where you've
been, and you think about where you are,
you can't help but
think through those moments.
And I think it's important that we
are okay talking about those moments.
Because the reality is,
it's those moments that anchor us.
It's those moments that teach
us empathy or humility.
Those moments that showed us grit and
tenacity.
And so we meet and I've met so
many amazing people along the way.
But the real lessons come from those
everyday people and for me, that was Otis
and Rosie brown when I think about their
sacrifice and trying to do the very best
that they could to provide for us even in
moments, their best was not sufficient.
It was their best.
And, I'm forever grateful for that.
>> I'm sure they're
extremely proud of you.
And you said it yourself, right?
You can't forget some of these folks
that are making the sacrifices.
You've said when you
are on the 50th floor at
JP Morgan-
>> Yes.
>> It's the people that
are in the mail room.
It's the reception, the cooks,
that fact, the ceiling, right?
>> Yes.
And a lot of times people say,
well, what do you mean?
And again, being anchored in history.
And when you think about when and
how did my melanin,
my complexion answer Corporate America.
It entered through the halls of
janitors and cooks and secretaries.
That was the first introduction
to our brilliance.
And so when I, I would say to everyone
when I would look on the 50th floor and
I see Rockefeller I would say, he couldn't
imagine me being the face to his bank.
Having the privilege to
lead the consumer bank, but
you have to give homage to those who did
not have these amazing rented titles,
but they showed up with strong character.
They showed up with a level of excellence.
They showed up when they
weren't really being seen.
And so when I think about where I am
today, I think about those cooks and
those janitors I was just
putting cracks in the ceiling,
that over time I could exist and so
many people like me could exist.
And so I have a lot of respect to those
who've come before me that were enrolls,
that truly paved the way.
>> And I'm sure your leadership
is unnoticed by them, right?
You literally pulled stories where
you go down in the mailroom and says,
it all starts here, right?
Absolutely, I mean, look,
when I think about Otis Brown, or
when I think about so many people,
specifically, people of color,
many times we are disproportionately
in those lower wage jobs, or
we are in those entry-level jobs.
And so, it does not escape me that,
when I have an opportunity to be a CEO or
to be in a leadership position, to make
sure I go and see those individuals.
To make sure that I can talk about
the strategy and the role that they play.
And so, when I would go to the mailroom, I
would tell the young individuals that when
you see us talking about earnings or
talking about that client experience,
I would say,
I want you to brush your shoulders off and
know that you had a role to play,
because you started the process.
You had to do your job with excellence,
when people made their payment in auto,
to make sure it went to the proper shoot,
so, it would post on time.
And so by connecting them and
understanding that they matter, and
that they have a voice and that they have
a role to play, what I get in return is
that the people furthest removed from our
results, see their role in our results.
And what was so great is, after I was
telling them how awesome they were, I
remember one of the gentlemen looked at me
and he was like, you welcome we got you.
[LAUGH] And I just think that's
important because that's Otis Brown.
My dad worked in a warehouse and he's
brilliant, he didn't go to college, but
he's brilliant, and he taught me so much.
And I just think it's important to make
sure that we model what it means to see
everyone.
Not just in the big town halls, not
just in the employee appreciation notes,
but in what we do and how we do it.
And taking the time to engage
with those furthest removed,
is what really embodies culture,
and what I try to do every day,
see the unseen, and see the people
that really help, build your company.
>> Your leadership is jumping
from the screen right now.
I don't want to cry ten
minutes into this interview.
So, I think we have a quick video to show
how much folks appreciate your leadership,
so, we can see [INAUDIBLE].
>> Wow.
>> So inspiring,
I can't even express it to you,
I think it's one thing to be able to
come in this building every Saturday.
And we're so grateful to be here, but
to be able to see all these black
entrepreneurs doing so amazing,
but you're the CEO of.
That's [INAUDIBLE]
>> [CROSSTALK]
[LAUGH]
>> My god, it is just amazing to see that
you look like me, and you're able
to do that, and have that impact.
So, thank you.
>> I know this was viral a couple
years ago, 2019, but Chloe, I mean,
I can't Chloe, kills there [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, she's now like my niece.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I keep in touch with her,
she's amazing.
And you're right it went viral,
because it was a real human bowman.
And I think it touched a cord
in the art of possibility.
When people can see themselves in
what it means to be excellent,
they can then be reminded
that they are worthy and
deserving of that same
level of excellence.
And I think that's what Chloe and I
represented with the beautiful words that
she expressed in such a real and human
moment and it was really heartfelt and
I think people could relate to it,
people can understand it.
And I think, hopefully,
it's a nod in the right direction of
the work we still need to
do in corporate America.
And, I think, it's important because
when you look at the stats, right?
And I know this is a business class,
so I have to try a few stats here-
>> Let's do it.
>> It is Stanford, after all, but
I was looking at the Fortune 500.
And when we talk about all the work,
that we do,
all the initiatives that are out there,
we have to be outcome driven.
And the reality is there's only, I think,
41 women, that are leading a fortune 500,
there are 16 Latinx, and
there were 3 African Americans.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so, we can talk about all the
things that we're doing, but we have to
ask ourselves if we believe that talent is
created equally, and opportunity is not.
It bears out when you
look at the shape and
the profile of those who
are leading Fortune 500 companies.
Which says to me,
we still have a lot of work to do.
And it really, I think, hits a nerve
when you see the video, Chloe and
I having a moment, because it matters.
And, clearly, the outcomes are not
bearing what we believe and
what we aspire to be true as a country.
>> For sure, I love the stats and
the backs, I think they ground us.
The one that I wanted to mention since you
are very vocal on financial equity and
health for everyone, not just leaders-
>> Yes.
>> Is the median net worth of
black single men and women,
versus single white men and women.
I'll let you share the information but,
I think that's important to return to
the numbers, and remember we fight for
progress and want progress, but
there's still some very
harrowing statistics out there.
>> Yeah, and
I think when you look at the numbers,
it tells us what all we still
have to do to make sure that
there's full inclusion and
equity for all Americans.
And so what you're referencing is the
median net worth of single black men and
women are like 200 to $300
versus white men and women,
which is around 15 to $28,000.
And so when you think about that,
we have to say, what is going on?
And we have to take a moment and
say, what has to change?
And what do we do?
What are those choke points
that we have to unlock?
Because, clearly,
as a society, as a human race,
we cannot be okay with those statistics.
And we have to know that we can
do better and that, surely,
it cannot be all of the melanin
that's causing these results.
It's not the melanin,
there's something else that's going on,
that we have to lead boldly and
be provocative about these stats, but,
more importantly, be bold about what
we can do better to move forward.
>> As a starting point,
maybe you mentioned in a TED talk, right?
We just need to talk about money, period.
And you told the story money's personal,
there's a lot of stuff that comes with it
when you bring it up in a conversation.
But you told the story, right?
Of your dad and the 401k, and
just the knowledge of knowing that
existed perhaps could have changed
the financial situation, right?
>> Yeah, I mean, when I think about my
father, and I think about my parents, and
I think about all the sacrifices
that they made for us.
And I remember after I
graduated from college and
I was looking at my dad's statement,
and to have to tell your father
that you don't have enough,
not even close, to be able to retire.
And what angered me is that
the 401k was for him, but
he didn't see it within himself.
So, the information or the way in
which the information was shared,
he didn't think it was for him.
And so, when you think about
these opportunities, and
you think about minorities
participating in the stock market or
understanding the power of compounding.
Or you think about
the homeownership rates, or
you think about small businesses,
you can go on, and on,
all of the things that can unlock wealth,
generational wealth, there's more to it.
The information may be out there, but can
people see themselves, are we making it
where folks do not have to feel as if, I
didn't go to college, so it's not for me.
Or this was something
that wasn't discussed,
and I don't want to seem less smart.
And so, I think the opportunity for us,
is to really make sure That we tap into,
not just the information,
but how it's presented.
And you're right, I talk about
it in a TED talk because I said,
we have to talk about this
without shame or judgement.
>> [LAUGH]
>> No shame, no judgement.
It's not where you start,
it's where you end up.
And whether it's $1 a day or a quarter,
just get going and get started.
Because that power of compounding and
that behavior, over time,
can really mean the difference
when you think about your wealth.
But, clearly, a lot of times
when people see their finances,
they associate their financial
situation to their self-worth.
And I like to say, your net worth
does not define your self-worth.
And I just think that's so
important and we have to be okay.
I like to say, we know how to keep it 100,
especially, young people.
But we have to know how to keep it 700+.
We have to know how to get started and
be okay with where we are, but saying,
hey, we can make these steps to have
a better outcome and a better tomorrow.
>> Absolutely, it's a great message.
It's a scary, I think, thought for
folks to make that initial plunge.
>> Yes.
>> Hopefully we can get more,
us minorities taking the plunge,
understanding, as you said,
the power of compounding, and hopefully
a more financially sound future for them.
>> Absolutely.
>> And beyond financial equity,
it's obviously been a tough year for
a lot of different reasons.
I don't want to just ask about race,
outright.
I think when you were talking
to the mayor of Arlington, and
I know Arlington is a super important
place for you, you said something that
actually it hit me pretty deep,
which is extraordinary is kindness.
>> Yeah.
>> So, if we're just kinder with
each other, and we're more patient,
perhaps that's the starting point
to ending some of these tensions,
which seem to be wrapped up in other
things the news likes to highlight.
>> No, I think you're right.
And I like to say, what it means to be
extraordinary, are your ownable assets.
Extraordinary is kindness,
extraordinary is laughter.
I also think extraordinary
is doing the work.
And so many times when we have these
conversations, particularly around race or
inequality, we want to start
in the middle of a chapter.
But I think the way in which we can
unlock and make real progress, is to get
proximate with the history, and to really
understand the structural inequities.
To really understand what it means when
you grew up in a segregated south.
To really understand books
like first school, and
the history that we have in our society
that has caused so many inequalities.
And it's not, again,
to make people feel bad or ashamed,
but it is to get to the root.
In business, as you know, in business
school, you have to get to the root cause,
the root cause.
And that's what you do in business.
When you see something you say,
what is the root cause?
The root cause analysis.
And so I think that if we can get to
the root of the matter, and get educated,
and get proximate, and
do it with a headset of kindness,
a headset of saying, I want what you want.
I want my children to breathe just like
you want your children to breathe.
I want a full opportunity just like
you want a full opportunity, and
then we do the work.
And I do think that if we
work on ourselves, and
do it with kindness, and
do it with a level of curiosity,
then it's us that become
the people in positions of power.
It is us that can then be that mom,
at a school and
volunteering and doing the work.
It is us, it is humanity that
will unlock the progress.
Policies and
everything else will change when it's the
people that decide that we can do better.
And I think kindness is at
the heart of everything that we do,
when you think about progress.
>> That's incredible, if the people
decide, and kindness will be unlocked,
everything will follow.
>> Absolutely.
>> That would be ideal.
>> That's the work, right?
That's the good trouble we
have to get into, and stay in.
>> It's a fight worth fighting.
But as you said, it's not new.
There have been many people before
us that have engaged in this.
We need to learn from those lessons and
continue to work forward.
>> The thing that I think is so
powerful about that is that,
if we're honest with ourselves,
we have made progress.
And it is easier than it was for
my grandparents.
It is easier than it was from those
who enslaved into the country.
So, progress is slow,
progress does not go in a straight line.
It goes up and down, but
it's progress, all the same.
And so, I think that it's important
that when we are in positions of power,
that we understand the platform.
And that we understand that it's more than
just delivering on the financial results.
It is about shaping a culture.
It is about using our voice to
make real progress in our country,
and I think that's good for business.
It's good for community.
But is also, for me,
why I believe I'm in this [INAUDIBLE].
It is to stay in that good trouble and
to create that art of possibility,
so that more people can ascend, and
really see the power that they have, but
also be rewarded with their hard work and
effort.
And so progress is slow,
but we are making progress.
And I think we have to stay hopeful.
At least, I'm hopeful, I have no choice.
I have a lot of kids.
And I have to stay hopeful and believe
that they will have better days than I and
those before me.
>> Under your leadership,
I'm sure they will, and
they'll be leaders themselves, very soon.
>> Absolutely.
>> So, Shonda, I want to end with
a couple questions that are directly for
the Class of 2021.
They have 20 days till they graduate.
So we'll look for some advice from
you on a couple different topics.
>> Okay, great.
>> Amazing, so, firstly, folks they love
the titles, the gold-plated careers.
But as you said earlier, you rent your
title and you own your character, right?
>> Yes.
>> So, what advice, and
you made this decision for yourself,
choosing the right position over money.
What advice would you give folks that are,
perhaps,
grappling with that decision right now?
>> Well I'm glad you brought that
point because I do think I want you
all to write down and to know that you
rent your title, you own your character.
So you should show what
was your ownable assets.
And so when you're thinking about the job
and you're thinking about the opportunity,
what I would say is,
make sure that whatever role you take or
whatever position, understand the culture.
Understand who you are.
Understand and know that you
have the power to make progress.
And I also think that it's important to
make sure that, whatever road you travel,
to stay intellectually curious, and even
if you take a role that may not be ideal,
understand that there's
a lesson in that moment.
There's a lesson in that journey.
And so, it's not so
much about which job you take or what,
just make sure that whatever you decide,
stick with it, take the lesson,
and know that I would rather take
those lessons getting started, so
that when you level up, you're prepared,
because you've been tested.
Versus running from job to job,
the minute it gets a little tough, or
you don't like something,
then how are you going to grow?
And then how are you going to have
a perspective to be able to tell someone
else something along the way?
So, rent your title, own your character.
When you think about your role,
stay curious, stick with it, and
think about what's the lesson that
you're supposed to learn, and
what is the gift that you're supposed
to give to that environment?
>> Strong start, I like all that advice,
I'm going to follow it myself.
>> All right.
>> How about a mentorship?
So you've mentioned before, perhaps you
don't learn as much as you think from
the person seven levels
above you in the C suite.
Perhaps it's the people around you
that you should be looking for, for
the learnings.
What did you mean by that?
>> My gosh.
So, the minute we get into corporate
America, all of a sudden we're like,
I need these mentors that
are already in these big rolls,
but I like to remind people
mentorship is all around you.
It's all around you.
And what I mean by that, is when you
think about who you are, there's so
many facets of you.
So how could one person
give you that entire gift?
So I get mentored by sister.
She shows me the power of service of how
she shows up on my behalf with excellence.
I am mentored by having this
opportunity with the youth,
the people that are going
to do amazing things.
And so
my point is mentorship is all around you.
It's in the history books that you read.
It's in the observations of the youth,
it's in senior leaders as well,
but the most important thing is to
understand that if you are truly trying
to hone your skills, then you should
hone that skill of not limiting who
mentors you by their rented title.
But who is showing up in a way that can
teach you something that can iron your
hone your skill set in a way that
you can be a better human and
I just think mentorship is all around us.
You have to just open up your eyes and
be willing to receive it in whichever
form that it presents itself.
>> Absolutely and
I think closely on that topic around
looking to the folks around you for
leadership and for inspiration, your
friends and perhaps your partner as well.
I think we have a couple
of pictures to show
>> You guys did your work.
[LAUGH].
>> I love the fact check those comments.
There, key to a long relationship
flirt with your husband.
>> I love that.
>> Best board CEO way to lay except that
the most important business decision you
make is your partner,
>> Yeah.
>> I understand you guys have
a wonderful relationship
>> Me too.
>> What advice would you give
the MBAs on their friends and
if you want their partner selection?
>> Well, I love this question, because so
many times when we think about
a relationship, you may say,
I want him to do this, and I want him
to do that or this or that for me.
But it's the matters of the heart.
And the reality is I have a man
who is anchored in character.
I have a man who believes that
his role is to lighten my load,
who understands that I
want to impact the world.
And so as a result,
he's an engineer and a marine.
But he's a stay at home, dad.
He runs our family office I like to say.
[LAUGH] And Buddy, but what I just
think it's about a partnership and
it's about those ownable assets and so
whomever you choose to spend your time
with, whether it's in life or
in friendships.
Think about the character, think about
the ownable assets because that's really
what's going to help you navigate
your storms, your ups and your downs.
And I'm just incredibly blessed that I
have a partner who truly is my partner
in life.
And most importantly, he's on this journey
to help me be the best version of myself
that I can possibly be.
And he's additive to who I am and
being able to unlock all of who I am when
it comes to being a mother,
a philanthropist, an executive and
all the other titles that
are part of my portfolio.
>> That's incredible.
I love to hear that.
I think it's wonderful advice.
Find someone additive, who supports you,
who makes a better person, right?
>> Absolutely, absolutely.
>> Okay.
One more on the career side and
then we'll give you our final question.
So, obviously you took the new role at TI.
>> Yes.
>> What advice would you give to folks
as they make these decisions craps,
they love the rule they read before but
now opportunity arises,
what is kind of your thought process and
how do you make those decisions?
>> Yeah, it's such a great question
because I absolutely loved my prior role.
I loved the company, the people.
I felt like I still had a lot of runway.
But I also believe in
the art of possibility, and
I believe in getting uncomfortable.
And clearly, if there was a word to
describe 2020, it was uncomfortability.
But what was beautiful is when you
sit down in your quiet moments and
you ask yourself,
are you reaching your highest potential,
not from a title perspective,
from an impact perspective.
And when I realised that I wanted to
be open to the art of possibility
that maybe I can show up in a way
that could be even more impactful,
TIAA came knocking at the door.
And now what I can say in hindsight, of
course, is that to be able to be the CEO,
a TIAA full circle when I think about my
parents, to be able to be the first woman,
third African American to make history
in so many ways, that's impact.
I like to say, sometimes we say,
we're trying to crack the ceiling.
Forget the ceiling, just step outside.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE] Sometimes we just have to
get out of our box of comfortability and
know that we are worthy and deserving.
And taking a risk is not a risk
if your objective is impact.
If your objective is something
higher than yourself,
then you have to be okay with getting
uncomfortable and then going for it.
Going for it.
Listen to that quiet voice.
Do the work, be prepared.
Don't leave when you're frustrated or mad.
Make sure you have a clear mind and
a clear heart.
And listen to what could be there for you.
And be okay with it.
What's the worst that could happen?
>> Pretty good advice,
another set of incredible lines,
forget the ceiling step outside.
It seems like you've
practiced this before.
>> No hey, it's just real.
It's so real.
And I try to I always say
model the behavior you aspire,
just don't talk about it, be about it.
And so for me, when I'm sharing with
all of you is what I've experienced.
It's how I make sure that I'm
always stepping into larger and
larger containers and
not feeling that limited.
And sometimes, especially as a woman,
as a black woman,
those limitations can feel heavy.
And that's when you have to say when
people are are saying things or
maybe marginalizing you, you have to
do like when you receive something
in the mail and it's not addressed to you,
you return that to sender.
And so, if people are coming for
me on things that are not me or
do not define me,
I'm not going to own that.
I'm just going to politely just
return that back to sender,
because that is not who I am.
And that means I'm limitless.
And that means if I have to step outside,
that's what I will do.
>> Incredible.
One last question for
you to Shawn that would ask us
to all the speakers this year.
In this challenging moment.
In these tough times, what principles
do you rely on as a leader?
>> Wow, I mean first my faith
is really important to me.
My character,
knowing that it's okay to not be okay,
knowing that this too shall pass.
Knowing that in our vulnerability
can be the unlocks of possibility.
And I think as a leader,
this notion of being curious,
not just from a business sense.
But I want to know you.
I want to know what motivates you.
I want to know what makes your
heart heavy, because as a leader,
I think if I can show my vulnerability,
then I create permission for you to
show yours and it's in that vulnerability
That allows us to take a breath.
And that allows us to no
longer wear the mask.
Paul Laurence Dunbar wrote a poem in 1913
Wear the Mask, we can take the mask off.
And then we can really focus on the work.
And I think that's so important when
I think about leadership principles,
character, curiosity,
being vulnerable, authentic, and
just knowing that the goal for me is
to be the best version of myself, and
that's what I expect for everyone else.
And in order for you to be the best
version of you, have to create space for
you to do that, unapologetically.
>> Thank you so much Shonda for
chatting right now.
It's been a complete pleasure.
What a wonderful message to leave with.
We have 2 student questions, and
I know my classmates are incredible,
so they're going to raise
the bar even higher.
I'm excited to invite
them to join [CROSSTALK]
>> Hi.
I can't believe I'm talking
to you right now.
This is amazing.
I worked at JPMorgan Chase in
operations for the last 3 and
a half years, so I know you as T.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Thank you T for joining, I'm so
excited.
Okay, so
we talked about this already a little bit.
And so maybe I'll position this
question a little bit more tactically.
But, one of the things that has always
struck me have been your anecdotes about,
leading people of all levels
in an enormous institution.
And the way you've done that is to build
those relationships in the mailroom etc.
So I am pivoting to
a career in hospitality,
which is a big shift from
operations at JPMorgan.
[LAUGH] And as someone who's seen you
model this behavior so well, I'm wondering
what tactics you could share about how to
build that credibility with those folks,
when you're education
levels are different, and
your perspectives are different, but
you're all critical to the work.
So yeah, I just love your thoughts and
thanks again.
>> First of all, thank you so
much Lauren, right.
Is it Lauren?
Okay, great.
Well, it's so great to meet you Lauren.
First I would say congratulations
on deciding that you want to pivot.
That's not easy.
I can feel it.
Your like, I don't know, but
you really want to do it.
Here's what you need to remember Lauren,
show with your ownable assets.
What makes you special, is that you have
your own story and your own narrative.
You worked in operations,
so you understand process.
You transfer that into hospitality,
that is really important.
The process, the change management,
the different roles, what people do and
how that impacts the presentment
of ultimately whatever that is.
You have that muscle.
And so, you may need to just be reminded
that the work that you put in over
the years is preparing you for
this moment.
Understanding the back office, and
understanding how important it is.
It's so critical in hospitality, because
you'll see the people that are cleaning
the rooms or preparing the meals or
doing the landscaping, and you understand
that they are so important, to
the customer facing part of the equation.
And then lastly, bet on yourself,
and show up with your character,
show up with your intellectual curiosity,
show up with your humble spirit,
show up with that smile,
show up with that level of,
I don't know anything about it, but I'm so
excited to show up with all of that.
Because that gets that expression,
that look you just gave,
that's what's warming,
that's what's inviting, and ultimately,
that's where your magic lies,
that's where your superpower lies.
>> Thank you so much.
I feel so known in 2 minutes.
>> [LAUGH] It's real though,
it really is real.
So good luck to you.
>> Thank you.
You look fantastic
>> Hi T.
>> Hi.
>> It's an honor you're here with us.
Like Chloe, I am in awe and I'm just so
grateful to see you on the screen.
So I really appreciate that.
I actually have to give credit to this
question to one of my classmates who
inspired it, Danielle.
And my question is,
sometimes if there is a CEO who is from
an underrepresented background,
or who is a woman, Q&A,
his fireside chats,
etc often focus on that identity.
And I mean,
we've talked about this already today, and
these questions are important.
But I also imagine that it can be somewhat
draining to have to answer what it's
like to be a black woman
in your role sometimes, and
other CEOs don't have to do that.
So I'm curious to hear from you,
what question do we not ask you enough?
And if you're willing,
could you answer that question for us?
>> [LAUGH] Wow, what a powerful question.
You said Danielle, I gave you that.
Well, shout out to Danielle, and
to you Chelsea for asking it.
Let me attack it in a couple of ways.
First and foremost the reality is, being
black has shaped so much of who I am.
It has.
And the reality is,
I feel privileged to have the opportunity
to talk about being black or
being a woman because,
I'm trying to get the world to
get proximate to who we are,
so that we can change the outcome and
the narrative of what is possible,
and to show that we belong.
And so, I am more than happy to
carry the burden if you will,
because it's not for them it's for you.
That's what it's for.
And I know that so many women, and so
many black women still feel invisible.
And so,
if I chose to ignore that question,
or chose to just talk about
return on capital or SBA, or
earnings, you would still not
feel like you're being seen.
And so, I just think it's
important to know your audience.
And for me, I'm very confident
in my ability to perform,
you can check the receipts.
But what I really want to make sure,
is that a Chelsea can have a shot and
when there's more than just rather than I
leading a fortune 500 as 2 black women,
then maybe I won't need to
answer those questions.
And to be quite honest, if the question
wasn't asked, I would bring it up.
Because I need to make sure that more
women, and more women of color, and
more people of color, can understand that
their voice is necessary and required.
And I cannot water down our history,
I cannot water down our story.
And the more than I'm okay bringing
that narrative into the boardrooms and
it's a corporate America, from my hair,
braid, straight to my changing of glasses,
to raising a black boy,
all of those narratives are important.
So I'm not going to water it down,
and in fact, I'm going to make sure that
those stories continue to be stated.
Now if you want to ask what
questions people don't ask,
that I wish that they
would ask me more of.
I would just say more about purpose.
Because again,
my performance speaks for itself.
You cannot be a leader and not perform.
Period into story.
But what I want people to
really ask me about, is my why.
Why do I believe I am the one with
the privilege of having this seat.
And therefore I get to share more
about purpose and impact, and
my purpose is to inspire others.
And if I can share more about who I
am unapologetically, then hopefully I
can inspire more people, more women,
more under privileged or the voiceless,
to see that they have a shot and
they have a shot unapologetically though.
So hopefully that answers the question.
>> Definitely does, and
a very, very powerful answer.
Thank you so much, really appreciate it.
>> Thank you, thank you.
Such a great question.
>> Fantastic question.
I'm so fortunate,
my classmates is incredible,
as you've just seen in a small snippet,
lucky place to be in here.
Tashanda, we have a lightning round to
close, I hope you're prepared for this.
>> Yes, maybe not, but we'll see [LAUGH]
>> We'll see, [LAUGH] all right.
I know you're a basketball family,
so we'll start very simple.
Jordan or LeBron?
>> LeBron.
>> Okay, I like to decide.
>> I have to, right, the speaker
bringing brilliance to the boardroom.
I love LeBron, but
definitely love Jordan as well, so.
>> Okay, Kim Mulkey's 40 and
0 Lady Bears from 2011 to 2012 or
the men's national championship
team from this past year?
>> [SOUND] This March Madness was crazy.
>> It was great.
>> Wow, both,
I mean I know I have to choose, but
my gosh, both amazing runs, amazing runs.
>> That's fair, I was very happy to
see Baylor beat Gonzaga personally,
but-
>> Yeah.
>> For another day.
>> Another day.
>> Better album, Beyoncé's Dangerously
in Love or Jay Z's Watch the Throne?
>> I'm all about to bee hive,
so Dangerously in Love.
I love it.
>> Okay, should we pay off student debt
now or invest in our retirement savings?
>> [LAUGH] Both, both, work to pay down
your debt and always stay invested.
>> Awesome, last one, and there's no
choice, we just need your answer.
So there's a bunch of x consultants and
bankers and
folks that love their
points listening right now.
How should we spend those Chase points?
What's the best way to do it?
>> I mean, I'm all about travel, and
hopefully we'll be able to unlock that and
get back traveling all around the world,
travel.
>> Where is the first place
you're going after this all ends?
>> I mean I've traveled to Texas, so
I've had a little bit of travel, and
I can't wait to go back.
But most importantly, I can't wait to get
my kids on a plane to continue to see
the world, all around the world.
I just think it's really important.
>> Great, Tashonda, again, thank you so
much for this conversation.
It's been absolutely incredible.
>> Well let me just close
by saying thank you.
You have been a phenomenal interviewer,
you had me smiling.
I'm just looking at you and looked at all
the bios, you all are quite impressive.
The future is bright because you all
have made a lot of great choices.
And clearly being part
of the Stanford family,
I can't wait to see what you all do next
as a family, as a village if you will.
But remember to always reach for the moon,
because even if you miss you'll be among
the stars, and
your future is pretty bright.
So thank you so much for the time.
[MUSIC]